lorient c'est ton style ou pas bah non
[Rires]
c'est toute la vérité
ya pas mal pape en anglais ça veut dire
oui non et constate pas de m mais comme
ça le à ça pour être prêt tu veux qu'il
fasse une petite école en juin on a
comblé ont déjà alors il s'efface pas
accompli - gloria gloria ton accent est
aussi beau que le diamant qui donne ton
coeur un choeur qui rime avec bonheur et
ce soir tu vas voir le désespoir n'a pas
de place battez-vous carémeau sécurise
pas possible là jamais comblé mais comme
sahin mamie à temps des personnes gérées
fait des compliments que ça tu parle à
des gens sont économiques lorient et
compte en tout cas il est célibataire
tellement amoureux que ça s'il est
célibataire et nous avons le même âge
non c'est pas comment je sais à wes et a
dit que je t'assure dossier le koala et
coûteux car il est chaque le iie les
frères et lui et s'achever en fait quand
il fait c'est qui jette plein de styles
et et puis un moment il ya bien un truc
qui rebondit juste fait saquer dit
agathe
et voilà